now you're going to play fix you it's
one of the most beautiful songs coldplay
has ever done and i'm glad you're going
to do it live chris when you wrote this
it really was about the band and fixing
the band because like i i think the
third album you were kind of like ah you
know can we keep delivering
why were you [ __ ] at this point when
this song came out well i mean what what
was going on when the song came out we
were our fifth member phil had left for
a while he was having some health issues
and uh within the band we had some
addiction stuff and we had
strange relationship stuff and
trying to adjust to being in fact it was
only because of that song fix you that
we survived that time because
there's something really
lovely about that song and it took us
through the whole time that was the
first time we had like the worst reviews
and all of it things that we had never
prepared for
and this song in other words because
when you make a whole album you gotta
start with one song that turns you on
and gets you motivated to do all the
other songs you get so excited about it
this period of time was very difficult
but we got this song for it
when you try your best but you don't
succeed
get what you want but not what you need
when you feel so tired but you can't
sleep
stuck in reverse
when the tears come streaming
[Music]
when you love someone but it goes to
waste
what could be worse
[Music]
[Music]
i will try
to fix it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let it show
[Applause]
oh but if you never try you'll never
know
just
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i
will try
to fix you
so
[Music]
see a street
[Music]
[Music]
down your faces
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lights
will
guide you
[Music]
and i
will try
[Music]
to fix you
[Music]
all right
that's beautiful
you